david nakache bonjour merci d'être avec
nous dans la matinale de rtl france
alors racontez nous qu'est ce qui s'est
passé précisément pour ces jeunes
migrants qui sont sortis du bureau de
l'aide à l'enfance qui ensuite se sont
fait arrêter ce sont des jeunes qui
seront évaluées vous savez que quand des
jeunes arrivent et disent qu'ils ont
moins de 18 ans les départements en
france doivent les évaluer pour voir si
son cas isolés qui sont gays mineurs la
grande difficulté de tous ces jeunes
c'est que traverser l'afrique pour
certains passé un temps dans l'est dans
les prisons libye traverser la
méditerranée passé un temps dans les
camps en italie arrivé ici quand ils
ressentent la plupart du temps ils n'ont
pas fait que des documents d'état civil
qui permet de prouver qu'ils sont
mineurs et quand c'est le cas dans le
département des alpes-maritimes
pratiquer des tests au seuil la plupart
du temps d'être l'art qui sont majeurs
jusqu'à présent les jeunes reporters
et quand nous associations avocats nous
pouvons les aider bas on faisait des
recours au tribunal pour enfants et la
plupart du temps le tribunal pour
enfants nous donner raison
revenait sur l'évaluation faite par le
département reconnaissait ces jeunes
majeurs mineurs et les jeunes étaient
placés nouvelle procédure
les jeunes sont convoqués à l'aide
sociale à l'enfance au centre
administratif pour que leur notifie
l'enfant prise en charge dans l'anti
sembla voilà vous n'avez pas réussi à
prouver que vous étiez mineurs donc vous
ne relevez pas de la protection de
l'enfance très bien sauf qu'en sortant
deux policiers de la police delà des
frontières les attendant les menottes
les emmène au poste de police riz passe
une journée en retenue et
administratives sans accompagnement
juridique et ils se voient délivrer à la
fin de cette journée de retenue
administrative une obligation de quitter
le territoire français ce qui veut dire
qu'ils ont un mois pour quitter le
territoire
c'est cette obligation en fait ils ne
peuvent la contester que pendant 48
heures c'est se soucier type
d'arrestation ccv galles alors le
département répond qu ils sont couverts
légalement par un protocole qu'ils
auraient passée avec le préfet et le
procureur à public protocole que nous
n'avons pas qu'il refuse de produire on
la demandait plusieurs faux tribunaux
administratifs
plusieurs faux tribunal pour enfants et
refuse de donner ce document et nous
nous voulons contester la légalité de
cette pratique parce que si quand des
personnes en détresse savent que en
allant voir l'aide sociale et les âmes
free peuvent se faire arrêter c'est la
fin du service social français ça veut
dire que le service social ne protège
plus et ça veut dire qu'il ya une forme
de signalement de délation qui font
qu'on va voir un travailleur social et
qu'on ressent mieux notés par la police
c'est extrêmement grave pour ces jeunes
qui subissent ces arrestations parce que
ça ce concours dure violente parce que
ça les prive de l'endroit parce que même
si le jeune ensuite voudraient contester
sa minorité au tribunal pour enfants ou
faire une demande d'asile belle a
toujours une obligation de quitter le
territoire français sur le dos qui fait
qu'il est toujours tout sable à tout
moment et donc très très difficile pour
eux ça les met en situation de non droit
par rapport à ça mais c'est dommageable
pour l'ensemble des mineurs qui pourrait
arriver parce que ça va les dissuader de
faire valoir leurs droits et ils vont
avoir peur d'aller à l'aide sociale
parce qu'ils risqueraient être arrêté et
donc il ne faut plus aller faire leurs
demandes de protection de l'enfance pour
être reconnue mineurs non-accompagnés et
en même temps c'est extrêmement
dommageable pour le famille sociale et
pour le modèle social français
parce que jusqu'à présent le modèle
social français protègent les gens ils
en voient pas ils appellent pas
systématiquement la police pour venir le
chercher des jeunes qui n'ont commis
aucun trouble à l'ordre public
or justement qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
mettre en place selon vous sur cette
question de l'âge de ces personnes qui
arrivent en france on n'arrive pas
souvent à déterminer si elles sont
majeures ou mineures selon vous en
attendant certains contrôles qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait mettre en place la
première des choses c'est de revoir les
modalités d'évaluation
il ya beaucoup de problèmes dans
beaucoup de départements et dans les
actes mans le team
on est quand même à la pointe de
l'innovation si vous permettez parce que
on a des entretiens qui sont quasi
systématiquement à charge au lieu d'
évaluer la situation du jeune on lui
demande à lui de prouver qu'il est
mineur un jeune qui a traversé la moitié
de l'afrique et le naufrage en
méditerranée il arrive sans papiers au
lieu d'attendre que des proches du pays
au pays lui envoie des documents d'état
civil on leur met dehors on pratiquer
des tests osseux qui n'ont une validité
toute relative c'est vraiment la
mitterie selon si les cartilages du
poignet sont formés s'ils osent de la
clavicule et soudés on va déterminer
l'âge de certains jeunes
avec des résultats qui sont parfois
aberrants vous avez des jeunes qu'on
vous le voyez très honnêtement savoir si
un jeune adulte voit l'adolescent a
entre 17 ans 18 ans 19 ans physiquement
créé quasiment impossible a dit on ne
sait pas mais c'est le même cas souvent
pour des jeunes français mais par contre
ils ressortent avec un test osseux qui
dit qu'ils vont 31 ans et on voit bien
là à l'évidence que le jeune en question
même si lui il dit avoir 17 ans qui peut
peut-être avoir 18 ans ne peut pas avoir
31 ans on a des résultats complètement
sidérant et le g si vous voulez c'est
que l'administration se base sur les
résultats pour décider du sort de ces
jeunes et ces jeunes ont des droits
ce sont des exilés ils ont souffert
énormément durant leur parcours beaucoup
présentent des symptômes post
traumatiques
beaucoup sont passés par les camps
libyens avec des actes de torture il
faut prendre en compte la différence
culturelle
il faut prendre en compte l'aspect
psychologique il faut laisser du temps
pour faire venir des documents d'état
civil et il faut arrêter d'avoir des
entretiens bâclé ou on descend on décide
du sort d'un individu en une demi-heure
sur un coin de table avec un traducteur
qui parlent pas toujours le bon dialecte
avec des jeunes qui comprennent pas la
langue et qui sont dans l'incapacité de
s'expliquer vous la question de l'âge
elle ne devrait pas être prise en compte
lorsqu'à une personne et est accueilli
une personne ayant en tête accueillis
dans un service social si elle doit être
pris en compte parce que si le jeune est
mineure il relève de la protection de
l'enfance ça veut dire que tout individu
en france qu'à moins de 18 ans et quatre
parents tuteur légal pour s'occuper de
lui dépend de la production en france il
est un peu sous la tutelle ou l'autorité
parentale de des pouvoirs publics
français et le département le place et
l'aide à s'intégrer avec un
apprentissage avec des cours de français
j'ai regardé 18 ans donc l'âge est
déterminant on est obligé un moment
donné de faire une ne part entre les
deux mais on doit rester dans une
approche sociale
quand on a un un jeune un mineur en face
de soi ou potentiellement mineurs on
doit pas avoir une réponse par la police
administrative hore-lacy quand on va
voir l'aide sociale immédiatement dès
qu'on rentre pas dans la bonne case on
se fait arrêter par la police ont
rebasculé dans la police administrative
et ont un traitement administratif froid
et aveugle de jeunes qui sont en sibérie
cette détresse et là on a un moment un
mouvement lourd un monogramme
merci beaucoup david nakache d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je le rappelle
vous êtes le président de l'association
tous citoyen